michelle is with us in scranton
pennsylvania hi michelle how are you
dave i'm great how are you thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up very exciting um
my husband and i are on our baby set too
it's been amazing and to encourage
people out there
if you're starting this journey at 58
it's not too late
and they can change your life so
and the second most important part is
that my husband wants to know what you
think
for investing and
would you advise sort of to hedge
against inflation
um buying like some gold coins as part
of your emergency fund
okay um
no and i wouldn't suggest you buy stock
in home depot either
or apple or exxon
why because the price is too volatile
to use as an emergency fund the purpose
of the emergency fund is insurance
not investment it's there for the rainy
day
the umbrella is there for rain only
it is not there to fight off bears
it's just for rain
that makes sense yes indeed
um so as
so let's say we have the emergency fund
in cash that's all you need
is an extra you can put it in the bank
in a savings account if you want
and michelle i'll go white and i would
go a step further too because you're
wondering you said my husband wanting to
know about investing
and then specifically in gold but
nowhere in the baby steps do we
recommend people buy gold period so and
either single stocks either like he was
saying
but when it comes to investing in that
time still
not suggests investing in commodities or
anything like that so
in the market yes through good gross dog
mutual funds or in a retirement
vehicle like a roth ira 401 k 403 b
but in general our piece of advice when
it comes to investing is to stay away
from gold
so let me kind of talk you through
something too that's interesting so what
this tells me by though and the way you
asked the question was that your
husband's
been reading crap on the internet okay
on gold sites because a
he should i buy this you said as a hedge
against
inflation okay now let's talk about how
that works
here's the way you've heard of a hedge
fund right
now a hedge against something
goes with the thing so the thing doesn't
destroy you
meaning that if you want to do a hedge
against
inflation you would have to buy things
that are incorporated in inflation
inflation is the price of bread going up
the price of oil going up the price of
housing going up
the price of electricity going up uh the
price of living
going up gold is not one of those things
it does not follow inflation
there is no correlation between the
price of gold and inflation zero
there's no correlation between the stock
market going up the stock market going
down in gold
zero there is some loose correlations
that really what gold prices correlate
to is fear
or greed when the marketplace deems that
the world's falling apart oh god
and all the conspiracy theorists come
out then the price of gold is going to
go up
but that's what drives the price of gold
up not anything else
and so if you really want to hedge
against inflation you buy real estate
you would buy stock in exxon you would
buy stock in wheat farms
you would buy stock in things that go up
in
cost when inflation goes up when the
price of things goes up
the things you'd buy stock in general
motors because the price of a car is
going to go up
you buy stock in bridgestone because the
price of tires are going to go up
that's a hedge against inflation gold
coins are not
the only place anybody says stuff like
that is on their stupid but gold coin
websites
that's the only place that comes up
that's how i know where he's getting the
information
because it's technically the wrong
definition does that make sense
yes but so when gold is going
up in price that's inflation
right that's inflation does gold hold
its value no
not necessarily you go back and pull the
gold you can just go online and pull up
gold prices
over 50 years and number one you're
gonna see about a five percent rate of
return
it's got a sucky rate of return and
it's a freaking roller coaster at six
flags to get there
it's way up and way down
just to get to an a boring average
that's why i don't play in it
because it's too freaking volatile it's
too crazy to ride and i don't find any
millionaires that say i got rich buying
gold coins
none i find a lot of people that got
poorer buying gold coins
but i don't find any millionaires in our
millionaire study that says i got rich
buying gold coins so this is where it
comes from
yeah and there but there is a level
because i just had a conversation with a
friend about this recently
there's like this level of security
feeling like yeah but gold feels safe
gold it feels like i don't know because
you can actually tangibly
touch it and see it whatever the case
may be there's this element of like oh
yeah we're gonna buy gold because it
just feels
it feels safer that's what they were
saying and here's what here's the weird
part of that is
it's not when when is it safe when do
you use gold coins
when you use a bar of gold to buy
something
never okay i mean go back
to a complete collapse of government
and anarchy in the streets you know what
happens then
the first type of economy that rises up
is a barter-based economy
so when katrina hits new orleans and
wipes the freaking place off the
map because all the levees broke and the
whole place is laying down on the floor
crying no one ran around with gold bars
buying stuff
but a can of gasoline some brand new
blue jeans
some work gloves some bullets you could
trade that for
anything for about six weeks down there
right now you can trade two befores for
just about anything in america
okay with the price of lumber yeah but
nobody's walking around with gold dust
in their pockets
this is not the wild wild west we have a
medium of exchange
primarily electronic but also these
little green paper
paper things with presidents faces on
them that is our medium of exchange
so this anomaly this this weird thing
all gold is safe everything goes to gold
when all the when all hell breaks loose
the world falls apart
no it doesn't i mean you walk through
baghdad after they kill saddam hussein
nobody's walking around the streets
there with little gold bars doing stuff
immediately comes up with the next
dictator's face on a piece of paper
and this becomes your currency following
a barter black market barter economy
which is what follows anarchy so you go
from anarchy to stabilization
and there's always a currency that pops
up following with the next government
i mean when the civil war broke out the
south
they didn't run around with gold bars
they printed up
southern money which became worth
nothing once they were defeated right
we were defeated i was here i wasn't
here but i'd live here but anyway
but i probably won that old but anyway
but the you know i mean same thing i got
these little pictures of saddam hussein
on paper money that
this guy in special forces brought me
back and three bullets from an ar
right when he was on a thing there and
you know what that paper money's worth
nothing because the people that
supported it are worth nothing
it's gone but there was never any gold
backing any of it up
but so why does fear drive it because
you see i mean like the joke is i feel
like
on cable news networks it's always gold
commercial you know commercials
selling gold and that's it's it's
on this false premise that if everything
goes to hell in a handbasket
you're safe then you're going to be okay
if you've got a gold bar in your safe
yeah well that's so much crap it's
unbelievable it just doesn't work that
way
you know you cannot find a failed
economy
consequently a failed government that
has completely collapsed where
gold pops up as the standard it just
doesn't not in the last
300 years 500 years you find me one time
in history you can study it you can't
you know nazi germany hitler takes over
is on a failed economy by the way that's
what put hitler in place
okay and they had hyper inflation her
question was about inflation
hyperinflation
we'll borrow a load of money to buy a
dadgum loaf of bread so hitler comes in
to save the day he's going to fix
everything with a stimulus check you
know
so uh and goes into power that's what
happened
and but they never once went to a gold
standard
never once there was a lot of black
market stuff a lot of
trading back and forth but never once
did they do that so it's a fear-based
thing
and listen if you get your financial
advice on the same channel
where they sell walk-in bathtubs and
snuggies
and your commercial breaks or they're
selling you financial products right
with snuggies and walk-in bathtubs
that should be a clue right there